hello everybody and welcome to part 18
of let's play pen number the Black
Plague we're getting right back into it
the aliens are leading me on some weird
goose chase oh you are different oh yeah
yeah Oh should you get it allow me to be
destroyed by your kin I would show you
er they followed me into it here are you
follow bone huh there will be more will
you Sanford will you destroy all trace
of this place maybe no one combo ever
discover me above don't know maybe I
don't know
I haven't decided yet maybe I will maybe
I won't what's it to you what are you
gonna give me in return
let's see boop-boop gone you're probably
evil anyway I shouldn't trust you what's
in here anything nope nothing not a six
a single thing pencil god boop-boop okay
can't go out that way can't turn on the
light it's all right here comes the
decision I'll get ready it's gonna be
the best decision ever
one more pencil OOP all right technology
aha
awesome awesome dost programming oh this
looks familiar
oh I don't even get to make a choice I
must think think think
oh yeah think use your brain powers John
oh yeah okay alright is this decision
time
not yet I need to think that's why I
won't budge what the hell whoa hey wait
a minute whoa what don't know okay
really need to get out of here okay ah
oh no oh no II know was it all mean up
and that section goes away okay
Oh what year is it
where am i oh my no oh no I'm getting
scared
Oh bring it on Radiator bring it on okay
decision time Boop don't even give me a
decision oh no I didn't what ah okay all
right
immeasurable armed with this knowledge
you must have the strength to do with
that which I could not oh I had the
strength the turbine gate was quite
correct
we humans are dangerous headless herd
but intelligent individuals the numbers
of this facility sought to reveal to
control the turn gate and the Tulln gate
time to me for salvation the hive ran
its tests on me and I jumped through its
hoops like a monkey took me for
but I am no monkey the tusslin gate was
right and I am entirely unlike it I had
more in common with Clarence no I didn't
I promised I would send this email to
you I promised I would ask that you keep
all humans from this place for the sake
of the Towson gate and for the human
race I lied yeah yeah if we are lucky
then by the time you read this I will be
dead on oh if fate frowns we will all
perish the north-western mine is located
at reference nad 1.69 14.5 8.3 154 kill
them kill them all oh yeah oh so badass
oh yeah so badass oh I'm the best yeah
yeah oh kill them all
yeah they probably were pretty much
infecting my mind and trying to trick me
just so that they could survive I'm
pretty sure that's usually how it goes
the last-ditch appeal is never the right
choice that was a phenomenal game oh I
loved it I've never been more scared in
my entire life penumbra the Black Plague
everyone should play that game overture
to all frictional games you're awesome
love it I love it okay oh man that was
phenomenal I can't I can't even say how
much I love that game it was amazing
everything about it was amazing it was
the atmosphere was perfect
all but I was just so amazing and
awesome big muscles big brain I solved
every puzzle and I'm so glad that there
was only one time that I really got
stuck on a puzzle and I apologize for
that but at least it wasn't as bad as in
overture because it only lasted one
episode and it lasted
multiple episodes in oh sure so oh that
was great
oh yeah yeah everyone everyone go out
and buy it right now by both of whom I
think they're in a pack and I think
they're super cheap amnesia to play
amnesia oh man Oh Robert Pike Daniel I
hate you so much I'm pretty sure that
they intentionally got the most annoying
voice actor for that guy because they
wanted you to hate him hate him real bad
by the end of the game and I did oh I
hated him from the first word from the
first word I hated him and he made me
kill amiable I never got my hug I never
got my hug and the ending obviously as I
was trying to get away they were messing
with my mind and just destroying me
because they didn't want they wanted to
live but I showed them I showed them all
right once again thank you guys so much
for watching
I could not ah oh yeah save artifacts
use 12 okay three hours that's all it
took okay thank you guys so much for
watching I appreciate it I appreciate
all of you I never thought that you guys
would like my Let's Plays as much so um
I don't know what game I'm gonna do next
but I'm gonna do good one and I'm gonna
make sure that it's something that I can
commentate on that you guys will like um
I've been thinking you know some people
have been saying minecraft some people
have been saying other horror games I
don't want to just do horror games even
though obviously you guys like it when I
scream like a little girl and I'm not
sure if I could do minecraft because I
kind of want if I do a let's play I want
it to be fun and exciting and
interesting and something that I could
you know make humor out of and if I do
minecraft I could probably fill 500
episodes of minecraft with me talking
but I don't know if that would be
interesting I don't know I don't know I
may do minecraft I may do a Skyrim I may
do other horror games who knows but what
I will tell you is that I am in this for
the long haul if you're there to stick
by me I'm gonna be there for you we're
going to update five to six videos every
single day and I'm
not going to fail you on that that is a
promise five to six videos every day you
want the content you got it so thank you
so much for watching and I will see you
next time bye bye